- [Woman] And it was
you regularly say that
failure propels you,
are there any
instances in your past
truly where you couldn't
get over it and why?
- Nope.
(audience laughter)
By the way, by the way,
that's the same answer for
everybody in this room.
That's what humans are good at.
We all fail.
We've all failed.
My parents haven't been killed.
My child, I mean, there's people
that have their children die.
Could you imagine?
The shit I deal,
listen, unfortunately
or fortunately
depends on how one
wants to look at it,
I'm a pretty optimistic guy,
I lost three of my four
grandparents before I knew them.
Two before I was born
and one very early on.
So it's easy for me to be happy.
I have my shit
in the right order.
The health and
well-being of my family.
And there's nothing even
remotely close to that.
Not even remote,
not even remotely.
People have gotten
through much worse.
This why I'm trying to
recall our grandparents
and our great-grandparents.
People were
persecuted and killed.
We do not have real headaches.
You know, I don't know
why I have this
highly emotional and then
completely unemotional
part of me
but I mix them together
to create the balance
and that's what works for me.
Of course there's nothing
that I couldn't get up from.
Like every other
human ever besides
somebody who now lives in some
weird cave that
we don't know about.
You know what I mean?
- [Woman] I do.
- We are strong as shit.
We're really fucking strong,
we're just being
sold that we're not
'cause there's a lot of money,
a lot of money
in telling us that
we're not pretty enough,
thin enough,
smart enough,
good enough.
Fuck that.
I want to tell you you're the
fucking best, go do shit.
(audience cheers and applause)
- I don't think you can end on a
higher note than fuck that.
(audience laughter)
- It was actually do shit.